une première discrète et sans pollution
voici le bus 100 % électrique à petit ce
dès le mois de septembre les voyageurs
de la ligne 23 du réseau fébus pourront
emprunter ce véhicule innovant entre les
villes de versailles et vélizy
villacoublay
conçu par le spécialiste des transports
la société alstom s'est inspiré pour ce
prototype du modèle parisien des
tramways on a un concept quand je dis
tramway sur pneus c'est parce que vous
avez une structure mécanique qui nous
permet déjà d'installer tous les
équipements en toiture n'est pas d'en
avoir à la fois dans le bus ou sous le
châssis on a également 25 % de surfaces
vitrées en plus par rapport à un bus
conventionnel donc on retrouvait là
aussi un petit peu l'image du tramway
et puis vous voyez papier à trois portes
donc trois portes aujourd'hui tramway
donc une meilleure accessibilité et puis
surtout des dépôts requis sont beaucoup
plus robuste que des ports de bus lancé
en 2016 par le syndicat des transports
d'ile-de-france les bus électriques
rentrer ici dans une nouvelle phase avec
au total six lignes équipées en région
cette nouvelle génération de bus plus
écologique et plus confortables doit
permettre aussi de rendre attractif les
transports en commun pour les
franciliens pour décider les habitants
de la grande couronne à ne pas prendre
leur voiture
il leur faut des transports en commun
qui soit attractive ça veut dire avec
l'air conditionné
ça veut dire avec de l'info voyageurs ça
veut dire totalement accessible quand on
a des enfants des poussettes ça veut
dire ça veut dire un autre bus et pour
les habitants de la grande couronne
c'est aussi important d'avoir des bus
silencieux et non polluant la région ile
de france s'est fixé comme ambition de
rendre propre 30% de sa flotte de bus et
de cars d'ici 2020